hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing with our
1858 match between Paul Charles Murphy
and Samuel Standage Bowden and this is
the last game will be showing from their
match and it is in fact the first game
of the match the one that we still
haven't shown which we haven't shown all
the games but I've shown the one that I
was planning on throwing so this is the
first game in the match and also a very
exciting one so let's check it out and
also before we check it out I would just
like to make a short announcement I
received a very interesting video from
an excellent subscriber from Adam
Genesis he sent me a video he made he
made a video about a game between
Carlson and Nakamura from the Lindor CIB
rapid challenge but he turned the mousse
into music notes so if you're into music
do check it out it's very arty so to say
I will put a link to it in the
description below it will be the first
thing you see do check it out III
enjoyed it myself so getting back to the
game with efore by Boden and the morphe
replies with E 5 as he usually does so
Knight to f3 we have B 6 more figures
for philidor's defense and now the D
media to d4 we have a capture some
before and now Queen captures on d4 and
now more if he doesn't go for Knight to
c6 right away for his Knights to be
pinned but first he goes Bishop to d7
now nice to see six will will surely
kick away the Queen from such a nice
central square we have Bishop to e3
Boden continuous development and now
Knight to c6 the Queen retreats the d2
now which is a natural square you don't
go all the way back you don't block the
light square bishop on d3 so d2 is an
excellent square square for the Queen
more free continuous development we have
Knight to f6 and now Bishop to d3 button
does the same defending his eforp on
developing and Bishop to e7 now morph is
ready to castle we ignite the c3 Gordon
still not sure where he's gonna Castle
kingside or queen side and we have a
king sized castle by morphine and now a
while Bowden could Castle queenside then
we would have a very violent game which
of course
well everyone including Bowden knows
that it usually does for
Morphy but here it's okay at the castle
both Queen side and King side depending
on what kind of game you want to play so
here we have castles and it is as of mu9
that the disposition has never been
reached again and we have aged 6 by
morphe preventing any of Wight's pieces
on reaching g5 but also maybe having
some ideas of expanding further with the
g5
so with h3 by borden and now by bikini
th 7 square Knights to h7 the knight can
now be shifted over to g5 we have g4 in
those days it wasn't really a problem to
attack on the same side that you've
castled so g4 and now morphe also
attacks on the same side that he castled
with h5 they both want to open up the G
file and they will try to use their
rooks for attacking purposes so nice to
h2 and here are more features traits
hCAP trusts h captures and now Knight to
e5 morphine out puts pressure on the g4
pawn so f3 defending and now g5
completely blocking off pretty much
every every piece in white scam this
Bishop is now not very strong this
Bishop not really doing all that much as
this pawn is blocking it the knight
doesn't really have a good way of
getting back into the game so here at
Bowden finds a very interesting idea
King G 2 and he wants that place his
rook on h1 to be used on the H file for
attacking purposes of course and the
more he goes for c5 and now Bowden
continues with his plan with rook to h1
and now as you will see it is in fact
Bowden who has a very promising position
we have King the g7 by morphing Murphy
now also wants to shift his rooks over
to the H file and Knight the f1 now
preparing to bring the knight g3 and
from there you can go to f5 h5 and also
this night can come to d5 so a lot of
good squares for whites Knights so rook
the h8 more more free concerts at whites
rook on h1 and now Knight the g3 as
planned so f6 by Morphy defending the
the g5 point one more time and well just
asking white what do you play here and
now White has some very excellent
excellent options you can well 1
think you could go Bishop to b5 try and
challenge the bishop to remove one of
the defenders of the f5 square so you
can use the f5 square for the knight you
you can play Knight to the h5 you can
play Knight to d5 a lot of excellent
ideas here so Bowden goes for nights to
d5 right away puts pressure on the
Bishop here and also just it's an
excellent square for the knight so
Morphy goes back night to a faith he
offers a trade of one of the rooks but
Bowden declines nights the h5 with check
a Knight to f5 was also possible Bowden
prefers Knights to h5 check we have King
the f7 and now comes Luke 8 B 1 so
Bowdoin is really going for a more of a
more of an endgame approach here he
wants to move this Bishop he wants to
capture on e7 and then make the d6 pawn
a vulnerable target and now that's why
rook to d1 is played he wants to make
use of this and there is not there isn't
really much more he can do about this he
goes Knight the G to f6 again developing
but not really a lot of useful useful
squares for that night except h4 h4 will
be a nice idea so Bishop back to e2 now
preparing captures and the just Queen
captures this pawn on d6
and now Knight the h4 check as planned
King f2 and now Bishop the c6 so now
both of the Queen and the Bishop
regarding the pawn however Bowden
eliminates one of the pawns so this is
if you want to go for a more of an
endgame approach to this game or you
could just go for f4 and try and bust
open the position right away however
your own king is also an f2 so might be
not all that impressive
so Knight captures on e7 he removes the
defender of the pawn here and it's
actually very very smart as king
captures is impossible yes now you
defend the pawn but do you see how how
white wins here even pause the video and
try to find how white wins wins here as
it's very interesting while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those you who
were able to do it congratulations
unsporting that you can well be
basically capped for blacks Queen and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's nice captures on f6 and now
everything falls apart you're gonna
capture here well not there but you're
gonna capture here you're gonna remove
the defender of this and it's just a
very unpleasant
if the rooks are traded off then the d6
pawn becomes weak
not much black can do here and of course
if the knight is captured then the ship
captures here just immediately wins the
Queen
so instead after Knight characterize any
seven more if he said okay I do have to
part with the D pawn and Bowdoin grabbed
it with Queen captures and now as more
he doesn't want to lose another pawn he
defends it would be 6 so we have Queen
captures on e7 King captures and now
Knight back to g3 saying that this
Knight is now coming to f5 we have King
to f7 more if he doesn't want to distil
and with check and now rook the d6
Bowdoin take this opportunity to do a
nice rook lift we have King back to e7
and now Bowdoin doesn't want to work to
be one he prefers to keep his rook on
the h-file so he goes back rope the d2
and more few repeats King to f7 asking
or you may be interested in a draw
another threefold repetition I don't
think in those days threefold repetition
was a thing yet but you could just
repeat moves and then I'm pretty sure
they were like repeating moves and then
they you know looked at each other in
dinner yeah it's a draw but yeah f4
Budhan decides that he's not interested
in a draw here and he wants to now start
creating some other chances so more
pieces okay G captures Bishop characters
and now Knight H to g6 attacking the
bishop here and now the problem is for
example if you go something like King to
e3 defend the bishop black can just
capture it exchanging everything and
it's not all that impressive for white
on the other hand if you go Bishop to e3
try and do it like that then just real
characters on each one removes the
defender of the pawn here captures
captures and Morphy wins back his pawn
so here Bohdan goes for Bishop to h6 it
looks like a weird move but it's
actually the best move as you keep the
night guarding the pawn here and you
don't allow this trade so here at Murphy
goes rook to h7 he might be considering
doubling rooks and the H file here and
now
kink the e3 defending this pawn so now
the knight can move to f5 Murphy goes
rook aged rook 8 h8 now with a double
attack on the bishop and now Knight to
f5 defending the bishop a very sneaky
move by white here would have
in g5 just defending that bishop saying
to black if you captured then I first
played look if one check and after your
King moves only then do I pick up this
g5 point as now there is no target on h1
to trade so here after Luke 8 h8 we have
Knight to f5 instead of going for this
g5 idea and now morphe decides to remove
one of the defenders of the bishop so
Knights the e7 here we have Knight
captures on e7 King capture Sonny 7 and
now g5 a nice freeing move by Bowden as
capturing just results in Bishop
characters with check and this is now of
course very good for y so morph instead
moves the King King to e6 and now rook H
to d1 again a very interesting move by
Bowden and here more if we played F
characters and g5 he played it with the
idea that the bishop is now attacked and
the white needs to react to this another
thing morphe could have done is
something like characters and h6 he
could have given up the exchange here as
he is down upon and maybe try and hold
this because now that you see it of
course it doesn't make sense since these
squares are covered by the bishop if you
deliver check it's not much king e7 and
you don't have ways of exploiting the d
file for your rooks for example if you
try rogue th the wiggle out the rook
somewhere along the eighth-ranked then
you have like a forced force draw with
rook h3 check King f2 and now just check
and the King has to go back because the
bishop would be hanging so here we just
have a not a draw a repetition but a
draw by well agreeing to a draw however
here morphe played FCAT % g5 and now he
thought that ok after this after the
capture I'm just gonna play check and
have a nice game here use the H file for
my rooks I have a nice bishop a nice
night everything works in my favor
however Bowden has a winning move here
and feel free to pause the video and try
to find them the winning move for Bowden
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on defeating none other
than Paul Charles Murphy and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
its rook to d6 check and yes bowed and
played it now the point is
if you go well you can go kink to f7 you
can go king to e7 doesn't really matter
if King t7 then the ship characters and
g5 comes with check so here of course
more fever first played King to f7 but
now Bishop to h5 with check and now the
King doesn't have all that many squares
kink that e7 was played but now Bishop
captures and g5 with check with King to
f8 and here after Luke to f1 check it
was in this position unmoved 41 that
Paul Morphy resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here
well I will show how the game could have
continued as it's also very interesting
for example you're in check you have to
move like the King to g8 now comes Luke
to d8 check and after King to g7 you
just play Bishop to f6 check attacking
this attacking this and it's just game
over for example if King to h6 you have
a very interesting option of not playing
Bishop characters but rather rook cat
person h8 and now everything is hanging
if you capture this then you can just
recapture if you captured this then you
lose the rook so one thing that could
happen is Knight c4 check simply get the
knight out of harm's way
after king f4 now you could capture on
h8 but now white it doesn't even capture
the rook but rather there's a very
sneaky checkmate so feel free to pause
the video and try and find it it would
best defense It's Made in for but only
the first move is relevant so feel free
to do it while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the beautiful rook checkmate
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show it's Bishop to f7 and now
once you see it of course it all makes
sense the bishops the bishop pair and
the King are covering all of these
squares so the black king is stuck here
on the edge of the board the next move
rook to h1 is checkmate there is no
defending this like I said it's a way
the best defense it's made in 4 but
we're not I mean we're not interested it
moves like this to cover this since you
can just either capture it and then
continue again where you can go rook f2
and then it's just rook h2 checkmate and
that's that's just it
so after Luke turf one more feat didn't
feel it was it was me there was
you need to continue in the game so here
he resigned and this game one of their
match is the only game that bought an
one from their 10 game match the match
and that six wins more fee one win
Bowden and three games were drawn so
that's the game ended the match against
the same old sandwich Bowden I do hope
you enjoyed it we are continuing with
the saga probably with more fees clash
against the legendary mr. Barnes so
we'll probably cover that next and yeah
I would like to thank a young Nicholas
deal answer more than itself of
fulfillment incorporate funky monk 201
and Mario's gomila for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day